Kim Kardashian's making some more drama
today her Halloween post sorry made
headlines and it's not for her costume
the reality stars facing backlash for
using the r-word on her Instagram story
she was upset that some of her friends
couldn't recognize who she was dressed
up as on Halloween
take a look yeah definitely fake facing
some backlash for that she actually is
now apologizing for it she did release a
statement and we do have joining us now
from our 18 News Desk Brendon Jia Fran
Brendon what has Kim said in this
statement right guys so Kim released a
statement to us early this morning
already here for you she says I want to
apologize for what I said in a recent
video post she calls it inappropriate
insensitive what she said to the special
needs community she says I try to learn
from my mistakes and this is one of
those times please know that my
intention is always pure and in this
case it was a mistake I am sorry here's
the thing about about that though is you
know the video has now been deleted and
she says you know it was not her
intention but this isn't the first time
the a member of the Kardashian family
has been involved in this similar drama
right Brendon her sister Chloe did
something similar recently too right so
back in July we know that Chloe was
trying to reportedly connect to her
Instagram lives she was with her sister
Courtney and when they were trying to
connect to the social media app
apparently they were having some kind of
technical glitch and they didn't realize
they were live at the time so when they
were trying to when they thought they
were still trying to connect it it was
actually live
they used the R word and Chloe did later
apologized on Twitter kind of a similar
statement to Kim where she said you know
I should have never used this word I
hate that I use this word she questioned
why she used the word so you know they
their statements are always very much
apologetic but I think in the moment you
know it's a very in the moment thing
agreed I created it's very interesting
you make a good point about being in the
moment I think Brennan it leans on
though people not being need to be more
aware to what is right and what is wrong
and again as I said Chloe and and Kim
have done this in the past so hopefully
they'll learn from this and they should
learn from this because it's
unacceptable Point Blank period
absolutely absolutely awesome thanks
Brendan thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]